the smartphone that i wish i wasn't as
glued to
to the screen you're probably watching
me on right now right through to the
cars we drive and the appliances we have
in our homes like fridges
they all rely on semiconductors and
chips
to make them tick now it would seem
there's a problem with the global
production
of these chips and it's causing concern
for a number of countries
including here in germany if a big block
like the eu is not in position to create
electronic chips
i'm not comfortable about that it is not
good if you are a car
nation and you can't produce a core
component we need a global discussion
about how much real ability we can give
each other
or we will have higher costs if we
develop something three times
it's not just a question of production
that's causing headaches for the
chancellor
these chips are also crucial in
countries like
germany reaching their green energy
goals not least because
they're essential in the production of
things like electric vehicles
this isn't just a german affair either
the shortage of these components is
global
and has not been made easier by the
logistical and production issues thrown
up by the covert 19 pandemic
that all translates into businesses
losing money
with the global automotive industry
estimating losses as high as 110
billion dollars that's in sales over the
last
12 months simply because they can't get
the components needed
for production the european union is
keen to make sure it doesn't have to
rely on any global distribution networks
for its supply of chips
including those that come from the
united states that's why the eu
commission
wants production inside the block as a
continent
europe has to ensure that its citizens
and businesses have
access to a choice of state-of-the-art
technologies
that will make their life better safer
and even greener
provided they also have the skills to
use them when it comes to building
electric vehicles germany is in a good
position
as it has large deposits of lithium
needed to manufacture
the batteries they use electric car
company tesla is in the process of
setting up a factory near to berlin
however those batteries don't move
anywhere without the chips
and semiconductors that are in short
supply
with experts like the president of
computer giant ibm suggesting this
chip shortage could run on for as long
as two years
things may well get worse before they
get better
and that means delays in productions
losses
for global business giants and perhaps
even
a knock-on effect for the green energy
aims
of western countries peter oliver rt
berlin
you